[Music]
do you ever think about how much better
your life would be with me because I do
stop if I were to tell black ball
tonight why would you tell my brother
you think you can't handle me on your
own
this is not I think we should at least
try insurance debuting on IMAX screens
September 1st premiering on ABC
September 29 you're looking for you what
are these what if I told you there's a
place where people have powers like us
city of Adeline and I can take you there
we're in humans maybe I'm foolish maybe
I'm blind then can I can see through
this sandbox behind
brother sooner or later the humans are
going to find us got no way to prove it
so maybe on the first course of action
will be to try to destroy us what we
need to go to hurts now we need to
strike first it would only lead to war
are you speaking for yourself or for our
King
[Music]
Maximus is trying to take over aniline
are you going to kill your only brother
I have to rather me as your new king
after all don't put the blame on me
never don't put your blame on me you're
just a human
[Music]